well as we were just discussing there
this week the government announced an
unprecedented incentive measures to
support the economy through coronavirus
they are prepared to step up and pay up
to 80 percent of people's wages if they
would lose their jobs otherwise and also
provide billions of pounds of loans and
grants to businesses well the CBI worked
with the government and trade unions to
come up with this package under director
general Carolyn Fairburn joins us now
from Winchester thank you for being on
the program today you what would be good
to come up with these measures are you
happy with the final package well it was
an extraordinary package at the end of
the day I mean last week was it's
fundamentally a human crisis but last
week it really became an economic crisis
as thousands if not millions of jobs
were on the line and I had employers
phoning me in tears at the prospect of
having to let so many people go and the
package that was put in place on Friday
recognized two things fundamentally that
this was about keeping people in jobs so
they have livelihood and that we have an
economy that we can build when we come
out of this and also cash so the loans
and indeed the the foregoing of
suspension of tax so unprecedented
package there will need to be more and I
know the government is working on that
now but it was a breakthrough yeah you
say that there will need to be more man
we heard from Jamie Corbin earlier who
was talking about self-employed people
ninety four pounds a week not enough to
live on
talking about people who are renting in
that situation in particular what do you
think the government does need to do
well 94 pounds it is not enough for the
self-employed to live on and I know that
the government with with business and
with the Federation of small business
are working as we speak to find a
solution to this I think we just have to
recognize that this is totally
unprecedented what we're facing and the
pace at which we can do this is
determined by the people working on it
flat out coming up with solutions across
business in government that is a
priority another priority is that there
are some businesses in that mid size
range between small and large who are
also going to need a funding that's a
gap at the moment that's being worked on
and Sophia the final thing that has to
happen is that the banks ensuring that
the money is getting out of the door and
we're seeing a lot of action on that as
we speak as well as you say is
unprecedented I mean the amount of sums
that we could be talking about over a
prolonged period of time is mind-blowing
the sort of money that we'll all be
paying off perhaps a whole lifetimes is
it possible for the government to be
able to arrange this kind of money well
I think it is because we don't have a
this was not an economic problem when it
started so we have a fundamentally
strong economy if we can protect it if
we can keep people in jobs if we can
protect our businesses then when this
virus passes we will be able to rebuild
so it is a task worth borrowing for is a
task I think worth fighting for and the
way that we saw last week I think
business and government and unions and
communities come together is the way
forward it felt like the beginning of
the fight back Sophie it will take big
borrowing but if we can have a strong
economy coming out of the other end it
would have been worth it I mean what
we'll also need is for businesses to do
their part to act responsibly to not lay
people off to not take advantage of any
loopholes in this very hastily drawn up
legislation are you confident that
businesses will act responsibly I am
really confident of that what we are
seeing across the country is an
extraordinary stepping up by business
I'm doggin two distilleries who are now
making hand sanitizers two manufacturers
who are now moving into making
ventilators this is a uk-wide
effort that's bringing businesses and
communities together I am confident of
that if we have government creating the
incentives and the environment for them
to be able to do the right thing we will
see that so many more people are in jobs
today than were on Friday because of
action the government has taken an
action that business has taken you say
you're confident the business will act
responsibly and at the same time though
the Times reported this week that
easyJet had going to go ahead with a
hundred and seventy four million
and dividend payout to its shareholders
while at the same time asking taxpayers
for support for coronavirus I mean how
is that acceptable in any way yes yes I
think you will have a lot of businesses
who are now looking to how they control
their costs and how they protect their
people and you and I do urge businesses
to think very carefully about how they
make those judgments the only point I
was anything wrong is that we are all
[ __ ] sorry was the easy chat wrong I'm
not going to make comments I'm not going
to make comments on particular companies
I know that companies are looking
extremely hard of how they make this
fair this can't be made right for
everybody it's a no government can make
this right for everybody and no business
can make it right for everybody but I do
know that businesses are looking at how
they make this fair and we do need to
remember that we are all shareholders
through our pensions through our savings
we are all shareholders so how that is
it's done and I do work businesses too
to look very hard at how we make the
sacrifice fair across our country and I
think that's what the package on Friday
has helped us to do and businesses will
support every way they possibly can and
just finally I just want to take a step
back and just really take in just how
unprecedented this really is I mean a UK
government for the first time saying
they'll step in to pay people's wages
we've never seen that in wartime we've
never seen that in any previous
recessions and our economics editor
Eddie Conway described it as capitalism
being paused do you think that things
will ever be the same again I do think
that we are going to look we are going
to change as a result of this we are
going to be allocating our capital our
people in different ways to make sure
that this doesn't happen again in the
same way to prepare for pandemics to
have track and tracing systems that
enable us to to do things differently so
yes yes I do but on the other hand I do
think that markets are fantastically
good at delivering innovation and
getting people and capital to the right
things we are beginning to see that
we're beginning to see resources reused
across the economy to make ventilators
to do
the right thing and I think we will see
more of that so markets I think have a
lot to bring to this although there will
be lessons that we reflect on I'm sure
of that
okay Carolyn Fairburn thank you very
much for being on the program today
thank you thank you thank you